as a Portuguese adage goes what doesn't
belong to the government belongs to a
spirit or Santo the Holy Ghost in
English but it actually refers to a
consortium of the same name it includes
the Banco Espirito Santo Portugal's
largest private bank it's been in the
headlines because its parent company is
insolvent is the bank also facing ruin
the espírito Santo group is a widely
branch family clan five family members
at the top form the International
holding company that announced its
insolvency 20 percent of its capital is
in the bank through its subsidiary rio
forte the family also holds shares in
energy utilities real estate hotels
hospitals and foodstuff companies the
consortium is involved in more than 400
companies around the world in Portugal
the dynasty's financial problems are a
cause for concern
since the banks with their high-risk
loans were one of the triggers of the
financial crisis now - it seems that
shady dealings are behind the
consortium's bankruptcy there were some
you know misleading numbers actually
there were leading for understatement of
depth on the balance sheet around of 1.2
billion euros and after this news came
out you had also the story of the angola
FD angola activity which bears sort of
lost track to 5.6 billion in in credit
concession the news of espírito santo
spun an shil difficulties sparked fear
and alarm at the stock exchange in
lisbon and on the other European stock
markets within just one month the bank
stops lost more than 60% of their value
but the financial institution still has
sufficient reserve assets we know that
they also have an excess liquidity or a
capital buffer of around 2.1 billion so
and that I think that that amount of
money should be enough to contain the
worst not worse but at least the the
current risks we know now Goldman Sachs
has invested in Banco Espirito Santo and
the Portuguese are now also getting
advice on financial matters from
Deutsche Bank